ariel gracias por estar con nosotros y
qué significa para la población afgana
que el talibán controle el país qué
significa para las mujeres
bueno esencialmente lo que ustedes están
viendo es personas huyendo porque lo que
temen son dos cosas primero que el
talibán lo que haga es vengarse de todo
aquel que es captado como colabora
colaborador de los extranjeros así
traductores personas que forman parte
del gobierno prooccidental impuesto por
eeuu ahora intentan huir no solamente
por el aeropuerto sino por la frontera
con tayikistán y con usted están o sea
eso por un lado por otro lado hay un
temor real y es que el talibán vuelve a
imponer las normas religiosas de la
llamaría en su versión más radical
especialmente que influyen con las
mujeres y eso va desde la imposición del
burka
la túnica que tapa todo
el cuerpo femenino e incluso medidas
como pintar las ventanas de los
edificios con colores oscuros para que
desde afuera no pueda verse una figura
femenina
mire los llamados del talibán a dialogar
con la comunidad internacional en un
intento por no quedarse aislados podrían
dar un respiro a las minorías que ahora
se ven amenazadas en el país
quizás a corto plazo quizás hagan algún
esfuerzo por demostrar que no van a
volver a imponer lo que ya habían hecho
en el pasado lo que sucede es que es muy
complicado para un yihadista
dejar su ideología de lado cuando la
rigurosidad forma parte del adn yo
sugiero conocer el idioma yihadista y
especialmente una palabra clave que es
taquilla que significa ocultar la verdad
o mentira todo radical islámico está
dispuesto a mentir a un no musulmán para
imponer su verdad por lo tanto yo no me
dejaría guiar demasiado por las
declaraciones que hagan y menos en este
momento
y además se habla de que el talibán
tiene más poder ahora que en el año 2001
cuando estados unidos y sus aliados
iniciaron la intervención como ha sido
posible esto cómo se financian y por qué
son tan gruesas sus tropas
bueno por varias razones lo primero que
todo grupo radical islámico tiene un
sustento social conocido como agua como
acción social ya que dan servicios a la
población en un momento que el estado no
está presente lo segundo un gran
problema real que la presencia
estadounidense provocó también
conflictos con la población civil por
ejemplo
acciones en donde murieron civiles
afganos por errores o intencionalmente
de eeuu crea una enemistad entre el
gobierno y justamente aquel que era
captado como un invasor extranjero
tengan en cuenta todo país que ha
logrado vencer a una superpotencia se
cree que es capaz de vencer a cualquier
superpotencia y los talibanes en los
años 80 lograr expulsar los rusos están
convencidos que el tiempo juega a su
favor y que cualquier imperio no puede
vencerlos de hecho se conoce a
afganistán como el cementerio de las
potencias
gabriel que pasó con el ejército sin
presidente de las instituciones y las
fuerzas armadas están en el aire
lamentablemente lo que más nos sorprende
a todos los que vemos el medio oriente
es la rapidez con que el ejército cayó
porque cuál es la estrategia
estadounidense era nos retiramos de la
zona pero logramos entrenar durante
varios años a un ejército que esperamos
sea sólido y logre reemplazarlos fue
cuestión de minutos hasta que el
ejército oficial de afganistán caiga eso
nos muestra también que a veces la
injerencia extranjera en una cultura
ajena provoca un efecto búmeran todo lo
contrario a lo que realmente se
planifica de antemano